the race to vaccinate nations against
covert is well underway
pharma firms have delivered 447 million
doses to date
every fourth to the u.s many other
countries are still waiting
and the global figures not that good
only 1.3 percent of the world population
has been fully immunized
israel was the country that was
vaccinating the quickest we've been
reporting on them quite a bit
now chile is administering more doses as
a percentage of the population
the urgency is there case numbers have
gone through the roof
we'll talk to a doctor about that in a
moment first this report
the sixth plane from china carrying two
million doses of synovac vaccinations
against
covid19 taxis on the runway in chile's
capital santiago
every third chilean has had their first
jab already
that's the kind of vaccination rate that
other countries can only dream of
we are very happy not only because we
fulfill the needs of the country
but because we can now continue with the
higher objective to have vaccines for 15
million people
during the first semester of this year
chile is the world's covid19 vaccination
champion while the eu makes sluggish
progress on inoculation
the country of 19 million on south
america's pacific coast has already
caught up with
and overtaken vaccine heavyweights like
the us
and britain chile was quick to get its
orders for vaccines in early from
astrazeneca johnson and johnson and
fisa biontech but also from cynovac and
the sputnik vaccine
president sebastian pinera oversees the
vaccination campaign personally
vaccination centers are everywhere from
parking lots to football stadiums
nobody has to make an appointment anyone
who's up for their second shot is also
free to walk in and get it
officials want 80 of the country fully
vaccinated by june that means
herd immunity however the successful
vaccination campaign has yet to
translate into a reduction in numbers
infected
daily infections are reaching record
highs
health officials fear the campaign may
have inadvertently encouraged people to
become complacent about prevention
measures
and take increased risks
alexis colleges is director of the
millennium institute on immunology and
immunotherapy and joins us from the
catholic university of chile
how has chile managed to get so quick
and vaccinating
hi ben uh thank you for the interview
my impression is that it's been a really
great connection between science and
academia
with the government and the private
sector as well as the
um the citizenship
together with the fact that chile has a
long history along
tradition of vaccinations so
we have a very well organized for
several decades
the vaccination program here for other
practices
and so vaccines can reach all the way
from the north of the country to the
south
to every small town so we have a very
strong network
of healthcare systems that can provide
support for the vaccination campaign so
you reckon that's one of the reasons
behind this that
having regular vaccine campaigns for
other diseases uh
uh is behind this success it is
something that's missing in some
countries and is said to have led to
so much public skepticism about vaccines
in general
right so that's one reason and also
i think another major reason is that
based on the science the research we do
here
we were able to establish
collaboration scientific and clinical
collaborations
with some of the developers of cognitive
vaccines
and with one of them especially we were
able to establish
a supply agreement that was transferred
from the academia from the catholic
university to the government
so the government was able to secure
sufficient vaccine doses to
get this strong and massive campaign
rolling
that together with a very
active and efficient network of
vaccinations in the country
i think has allowed to move forward very
efficiently in terms of
vaccinating but i think the most
important point is that the
syrian society is very
willing to use vaccines
so they have been very the addition
the the cooperation from the people
to the vaccine campaign has been great
and
we have already over a thousand
population vaccinated
what about the fact that case numbers
are still rising despite
the vaccine drive being so successful
well they kind of overlapped so the
vaccine campaign started really
massively early february
and the numbers were rising already in
february
is a post-holiday effect that was seen
also in europe and
the us we have our
summer break from january and february
and early march so the rise
of the numbers come are probably due
to the holiday period the same
the holy season kind of the same
situation
that was uh has been observed in europe
and in
the us let me just ask
does it have anything to do with reports
that the chinese vaccine
is less effective
well there is data from
several clinical studies showing that
the cyanobacter vaccine
has efficiency
78 for the um
um cbm mild cases and
and about about 100 for the severe cases
and 50
for the very mild cases so we expect
these vaccines first to
start showing effect on the
hospitalization rates and the
under death rate um the studies in
turkey
and indonesia the efficacy data i
showed 91 and 70 and 65 percent
so the the thickness of the vaccine
based on the clinical studies
is uh between 50 and 100 depending on
the type of the case
so we expect to see that the immediately
um is able to keep the disease
uh severely reduced and how are we doing
also here
when a clinical study uh just to
check the vaccine and we have observed
so far
that about 90 percent of people show
antibodies after two weeks after the
second dose
so two weeks after the second dose we
have we see that about 90 percent of the
volunteers develop antibodies and those
antibiotics and neutralize me
okay we'll have to leave it there alexis
colleges director of the millennium
institute on immunology and
immunotherapy thank you very much for
being on the show today
thank you thank you for the interview
well the question of vaccine efficacy is
a hot button issue right now
chile was part of a large trial of
astrazeneca's vaccine
along with peru and the united states
astrazeneca says its vaccine is 79
effective after the trial of 30 000
people which look to clear the way for
the jab to get us approval
but american health officials now say
they're worried astrazeneca
may have used outdated information in
the trial and may have provided an
incomplete view of the efficacy data the
pharma firm is still crunching the
latest numbers and says it intends to
issue results shortly
and it's that part of the show where
derek williams answers your questions on
the coronavirus
do the different vaccines protect people
from the long-term effects of covert 19
many patients who contract covet 19
become what are known as
as long haulers or people who have
long covered there's currently no way to
predict
who that might affect although there
isn't
really an accepted definition for it
having long covid basically means you
don't return to your previous levels of
health
even months after sars kobe 2 falls
below detectable levels in your body
it's affected millions of people who
have a wide spectrum
of of longer term symptoms with with
chronic fatigue for example a really
regular complaint
there are two big theories for for what
might be causing it one is that long
covet happens when the body
can't clear out all of the virus or
viral fragments left
after infection that basically the virus
is
able to hide in some people somehow and
that the body goes into a kind of
of trench warfare mode
um the second hypothesis is that long
covet is an
unchecked autoimmune response so
so an off the rails immune system
in some patients experts say it could be
a combination of both
but there's no doubt that for people
suffering long coveted symptoms
the prospect of getting vaccinated must
be pretty terrifying i mean could
getting the shot
actually make you feel worse well
although i emphasize that we still can't
say anything for certain
there are a growing number of anecdotal
reports
that getting vaccinated appears to be
actually
helping at least some people with long
covet
we don't know why one small study and
peer review
also at least indicates that more
long haulers feel better than feel worse
after being vaccinated the problem is to
find out more
we would have to conduct trials where
some long haulers get coveted 19
vaccines
and and others get placebos masquerading
as covet 19 vaccines i don't think
that's going to happen to be honest
in the current climate right now i can
only say that the general consensus
seems to be
that long haulers should also be
vaccinated
and some anecdotal reports say
it might help with symptoms
and because we're all in this for the
long haul and not just humans
scientists are racing to protect animals
from the coronavirus
they often use the same playbook as for
people like social distancing and health
checks
and now vaccines this month the san
diego zoo inoculated several apes with
an experimental covert vaccine intended
for pets
making the animals the first non-human
primates to be vaccinated
the veterinary pharmaceutical company
zoetis
developed the vaccine san diego zoo
asked for help in vaccinating other apes
after a trip of gorillas tested positive
in january
the zoo has gorillas bonobos and
orangutans living
indoors which leaves them more
vulnerable to the spread of infection
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
you